السيطره على الارض غير ممكنه من دون
السيطره على ثرواتها لذا سارع بعض من كبار
المتنفذين الروس مع بدء الحرف في اوكرانيا
بالاستلاء على الاراضي الزراعيه
الاوكرانيه نتحدث هنا عن الاوليغارشيين
المقربين من الكرملين الذين سيطروا على
اراضي تفوق مساحتها ضعف مساحه مدينه
نيويورك كما انها من اكثر الاراضي خصوبه
في العالم تحقيق مطول لويس رجون الامريكيه
قال فيه ان المسؤولين الروس استولوا على
اكثر من 400,000 فنانه من المناطق
الاخرانيه وان الجيش لم يضع يده على هذه
المناطق هذه الاراضي باتت تحت خطوه
اليكساندر كشاف وزير الزراعه الروسي
السابق ومن نصيب شركه العائليه اوكرانيا
قالت ان شركه ادركونتلاكس الروسيه
المملوكه للكات بدات منذ اشهر التسلل
بهدوء الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه مدعومه
بالجيش لجني فوائد اقتصاديه من اوكرانيا
واستخدام هذه المكاسب للمساعده في السيطره
على المنطقه باكمله المخابرات الاوكرانيه
قالت ان الاستيلاء على الاراضي الزراعيه
بدا بانشاء ادارات مدنيه محليه في الاجزاء
الخاضعه للسيطره الروسيه شرق اوكرانيا
تحديدا في لوغانس ودونيس المسؤولون
الانفصاليون الموالون لروسيا باشروا بعد
ذلك زياره المزارعين الاوكرانيين في مواكب
مسلحه لاصال رساله مفادها انهم باتوا
المسيطرين على المنطقه اول من فقدوا
اراضيهم هم الملاك الذين خدموا في الخدمه
العسكريه او المدنيه في اوكرانيا اضافه
للملاك الذين يعيشون خارج المنطقه في بعض
الحالات تعرض المزارعون جديد اذا لم يستمر
في العمل كما اجبر ملاك اخرون على اعاده
كتابه العقود بما في ذلك سندات الملكيه
لتتوافق مع القانون الروسي وليس الاخرى
جون قالت ان حالات موثقه اظهرت ان مالكي
الاراضي سمح لهم بالاحتفاظ
بمزرعهم لكن العقود الجديده نصت على ان
يذهب سبعون في المئه من المحصول الى روسيا
او سلطات دونات ولوج
اوكرانيا تهدد بوضع جزء كبير من احد اكبر
محاصيل الحبوب في العالم تحت السيطره
الروسيه ومن المتوقع ان تؤدي هذه الخطوات
الى زياده النفوذ الاقتصاديه العالمي
لموسكو خاصه في الدول الناميه التي تعتمد
على انتاج الحبوب الاوكرانيه والروسيه
ادخلي على الغذاء شركه اجور كومبلكس
الروسيه تقوم بالفعل بزراعه جزء كبير من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وفقا للمخابرات واصحاب
المزارع الاوكرانيين فالشركه تشارك في
ضمان سيطره روسيا على الانتاج الزراعي
ومنذ يوليو
ظهر اسطول من مركبات الحصاد الروسيه على
ارض شركه اوكرانيه لتبدا في حصاد محصول
القمح الذي زرعته سابقا شركه اجرون
الاوكراني» من جانبها قالت الشركه الروسيه
ان شركتين اوكرانيتين تخلتا عن مشاريعهما
وموظفهما وان اجركمبلكس دفعت ملايين
الدولارات كعويد مقابل اصول الشركه وهو ما
تنفيه الشريكتان الاوكرانيتان ومزارعون
اوكرانيون تم الاستلاء على اراضيهم الكلام
رد على ملف التعويضات بالقول ان مناطق شرق
اوكرانيا هي الان جزء روسيا وان اصحاب
المزارع يمكنهم المطالبه بحقوقهم وفقا
لقوانين روسيا
[موسيقى]